playful
hand-painted
delicate classics such as coolant a
best-seller since 1790 in a new edition
all in white yoke violin is the owner of
the clinic Alicia porcelain manufacturer
or KPM the Berlin banker bought the
company in 2006 saving it from
bankruptcy as fine you might have I
never wanted to be the owner but I did
have a deep sense of responsibility for
saving this cultural tradition for
Berlin and for Germany the KPM boss is
preserving tradition but he's also
embracing modernity the bugatti lord
long or white gold was unveiled in 2011
individual fittings for the exterior and
the interior were custom made by KPM the
sports car is unique costing around 1.6
million euros what kinda tune is you
can't reinvent the wheel but you do have
to take new paths and her partnerships
with luxury brands such as Bugatti and
Bottega Veneta KPM has been working with
the Italian fashion house for five years
for kpms two hundred and fiftieth
jubilee Bottega Veneta design jewelry in
gold with porcelain medallions and a
special edition of the not Bottega
Veneta s famous clutch Frederick the
Great King of Prussia bought KPM in 1763
he soon popularized the porcelain
ordering twenty one of these dinner sets
with 500 individual pieces soon demand
for this white gold soared among the
aristocracy and well-heeled classes the
Berlin company works with famous artists
and has defined style across eras today
k PM has collectors all over the world
especially in Russia China and the
United Arab Emirates not Julie's in
Devon there are many wealthy people in
the world who want something a very
extravagant we can serve them but we
also cater to customers for whom design
is important
this dish is difficult to of each dish
is
new editions of 22 classics spanning 250
years were rolled out for the Jubilee
many items are already sold out they're
highly precious for example the Prussian
Kings snuffbox
costs over 1900 euros yoga movement at
the KPM works there are 180 employees
many of them have been here for decades
all functional and decorative pieces can
be custom made 1,500 casting molds are
stored here everything is made by hand
some pieces consist of more than 90
individual parts laying down the pieces
is difficult because if you do it this
way a foot can easily break and
otherwise you have to pay attention to
facial features the hands the feet you
have to work out the details just as in
other traditional companies the
porcelain painted here by hand is done
without using stencils the painters
apply several layers which are fired in
between that explains the high price of
some of the pieces
this Vaz from the latest collection
costs almost 20,000 euros here a woven
pattern is being created it's a
trademark of butea Vinita Yogurtland
plans to expand such cooperations with
luxury brands customers with deep
pockets tend to spend money on jewelry
fashion or cars rather than on expensive
porcelain the KPM boss wants to change
that to a line of wood we have inquiries
from private clients who say they want
this redesign and there are bugatti
customers who say they want their
existing cars refitted with our elements
so there's certainly potential there as
a devotee and Ohio [ __ ] quote two
hundred and fifty years after its
founding KPM hopes to turn a profit soon
with its blend of tradition and
modernity but charming
right